it's a [ __ ] nightmare greetings from
podcast Ville
it's Wednesday the 17th of June the
Church of what's happened now is brought
to you by stamps.com listen everybody's
avoiding [ __ ] crowds right now but if
you need to go to the post office print
postage at home and skip the lines with
stamps calm Plus save money on this
couch you can't even get at the post
office and now stamps.com is working on
ups you didn't know that did you get
discounts up to 62 percent listen since
day one says they're just podcasting my
wife started sending stuff out we've
been with stamps calm I see how easy it
is for she doesn't love it she [ __ ]
adores it
she prints up the labels probable pop
puts him on a thing the mailman cometh
pixel up and that's it he drops off the
mary takes the boxes with him it's like
[ __ ] stealing okay you save calories
you're not around people and you [ __ ]
ship the boxes yourself no drama no fun
no no nothing stamps.com it's the way if
you don't have stamps you should be shot
in hung that's not that if you don't
have stamps calm and you're running a
business what the [ __ ] are you doing to
start no wonder they don't blame it on
the porn chain
you're just a shitty [ __ ] businessman
you know I'm saying go to stamps.com
right now right now they got a special
offer for the church family a four-week
trial plus free postage and the digital
scale the GM when they said free [ __ ]
postage and a digital scale no long-term
commitments of contracts it's easy this
what you're gonna do grab a pen go to
stamps calm click the microphone at the
top of the homepage is a little
microphone at the top of the homepage
and press in church CH you are CH listen
you're gonna [ __ ] tweet me and thank
me like everybody else
it's easy go to stamps.com and press in
church that's it and stay safe my
friends kick this [ __ ] mealy
I got a physical tomorrow morning at
8:30 in the morning go see [ __ ]
doctor my new doctor give me some blood
get a finger up the ass is the first how
do you meet somebody on the first day
puts a finger in his ass they're
probably gonna finger my be no you ever
got exactly do they start touching your
ball they may kick off I gotta go
through all that [ __ ] tomorrow mom and I
gotta get up early go for a bike ride
like I take a shower polish my balls
really good so he's impressed and I'm
saying with my show this [ __ ] new guy
my set of nuts
his wigs gonna fall off I hope he has a
wings I Liberace that [ __ ] um
saying wait three season I pick up my
[ __ ] and I show him that ball set he's
gonna [ __ ] die a little Jimmy Lou I
don't even know his name is my new
doctor cuz my doctor retired anyway are
you guys doing it's Wednesday it's a
beautiful [ __ ] day to be alive I my
idea I woke up a little sad today
because today is a six-month anniversary
or super Bad's that [ __ ] six months
where the [ __ ] they going days I'm four
years I thought I would fall apart with
Superbad died I didn't fall apart that
as stupid as this Sam out of all the
cats I had I mean I miss Harry I miss
timmy like a [ __ ] you know I
miss Fidel but I miss super bad so
[ __ ] much it hurts because he was my
Goomba he could you know you didn't see
so bad all day you saw Superman like an
11 een then he disappeared and then he
come out like at 9:25 he come out like
what's going on and that I'd be leaving
and I come home and he'd be waiting
everybody door he'd jump I do my things
in the office whatever and then I come
out to the [ __ ] he knew I'm coming
out to the couch he'd be waiting for me
I'd come out to the couch he put his
head up against my lap and I just rub
his neck and he would just be pyrin
there meowing he bite me from time to
time and she took my hand off he'd
[ __ ] scratch me
he was a great cat man and uh one of the
guys I forget his name right now I
[ __ ] throw many names and what's
going on he made me a super bad girl oh
no way I have a super bad pillow at my
in my living room so it might I just
hold on to it when I watch TV I think
it's super bad and I also have a super
bad pendant in my car that's hanging
from my mirror so he's always with me
that's how much I believe in that little
[ __ ] dead that cat stole my [ __ ]
heart in a way that sometimes an animal
steals your heart man sometimes a
certain pet and you don't even know but
I talked this cheap we're getting the
party started today's Wednesday I gave
Lee five of these deer day he called me
back [ __ ] these little pills but they'll
send you for a loop me personally I
think they got something in them I don't
give a [ __ ] you want to dose me [ __ ] it
I'm like steak shake sack you know what
happens Shake Shack [ __ ] game
chlorines
well they do [ __ ] shake shack
supposedly three cops drank then they
are now three cops like drop zone yeah
they got [ __ ] poison that Shake Shack
and there's Ari
I thought it was Ari I thought it was re
[ __ ] poison if he's been bad for
everybody [ __ ] planes no more booze
Burt's at home his flag is at high man
happiness he was like [ __ ] League on
Saturday when they were burning Wendy's
even though wasn't the Wendy's in his
neighborhood at least they'll have a
little tear in his eyes let's go
[ __ ] this Wednesday if you ain't
doing something you want dick anywhere
but yeah it's been six [ __ ] months
and uh I told my wife last night I got
you know it's crazy the things you miss
and you don't miss I mean I miss Brody I
miss Ralphie I think around feel a lot
lately Ralphie starting to come up
Ralphie came up a lot in this little 90
day
period hismus I thought about him a lot
you know because you never really have
time to think about people when they die
so I thought a lot about ralfie answer a
lot about Brody and it's just weird that
they're even [ __ ] gone but it's crazy
when you miss a cat you gotta be a
special type of person to miss a cat or
an animal one I guess I'm one of those
[ __ ] fruitcake [ __ ] I'm saying have
you thought about getting a new animal
listen no no no respect that he deserves
so come on oh wait I got three cats left
they roll but I love him I still play
with him every night as I'm down to
three I've had 203 since day one I've
known 203 they're super bad two sisters
last night I got on the floor with
[ __ ] Lulu play with her she's got a
face that could [ __ ] launch I mean
she's just beautiful and how she lifts
her neck free and she lives her neck and
puts her hand on your am listen my neck
is it she then she just looks directly
into the eyes like you know what the
dude [ __ ] I'm gonna let my nails
I didn't a hand oh and little by little
she just pushes and nails into your
[ __ ] hand you gotta love it she's got
balls of steel a sister don't [ __ ] with
nobody Evie
hang up time we call hot bubbles cuz she
just blows bubbles when she's walking
away and running away they even get into
beefs like they don't lay down together
no not because Evie was part of the boys
club Evie told Lulu years are gonna go
[ __ ] yourself I wanna hang out with the
boys and then when the boys died leave
Evie was stuck on for Colt don't be one
of them one Lulu's like heart now you're
gonna come back to me my sister go [ __ ]
yourself it was my [ __ ] life what I
need you my [ __ ] life for so now that
I get along so Lulu sleeps by the TV we
we sleeps by the [ __ ] stairs and soup
grey I don't know where the [ __ ] she
sleeps she took over the garage that's
my wife Thomas okay
she took over the garage she lives in
the garage she got fooled in the garage
she's got her own bug
the garage I gave a fly the other day I
give a little flies too
I don't just put them in a jar sometimes
I smack them around and light them on
fire and you shouldn't get a mind I
think the Flies that come attack me or
your flies let you just train them to
somehow get me how many flies do you
have right now I got three in
captivation I got some [ __ ]
experimenting with I'm hitting them with
[ __ ] xanax and [ __ ] everything
just to see them one is be getting big
he's getting strong he looks like the
guy that for rocky and rocky fall from
Russia that's what it looks like this
[ __ ] you got a neck I didn't
take I only took one way off these
[ __ ] they all got one wing
there that's what I call them Johnny one
wing
Stevie one wing I think the other ones a
girl I can't figure it out but they're
always on top of their ray put her in
there like this those two flies have no
[ __ ] other debts you don't even move
too much I don't know it's wrong with a
little fly legs but anyway we need to
get out of this quarantine listen I know
I killed the fly about two months ago
and he came back to haunt me he's still
alive in the house he's bigger than a
[ __ ] [ __ ] group
I think the weed made him grow yeah he's
like a super fly you don't come out too
much but when he comes out you can hear
him again they disappears he goes down
to the ground he's kind of [ __ ] I
[ __ ] him up with the weed I gave him
like I just did science labs of them
like you know like Auschwitz like I just
gave them different sounds so live with
I met a live in the dark
made of live wood [ __ ] light you know
I hide them for a couple of months I
[ __ ] with them I feed him I give him a
little piece of [ __ ] from time to time
everything's happy with sounds you play
like different songs full of my put
Chinese music on and torched room just
to see what they reacted the plants
plants grow a lot better when you they
listen to music if you play a consequent
yeah so flies grown boobs to salsa music
they did they react tremendously to
salsa music they love Spanish music I
know it is about flies he's done hanging
on to the class whatever I don't give a
[ __ ] no more it's Wednesday the 17th get
your [ __ ] together you got six more
weeks unemployment [ __ ] you'd
better find a job you live in big time
right now at eleven hundred you smoking
cigarettes you hanging up on your boss
wait till July 31st
you'll be like half the people in this
town begging the suck a dick I've never
seen a town more people begging the suck
dick now than ever
yeah oh you got the small 50 you get
your dick sucked empty a good big suckin
they're on Twitter offering dick suck
sure they are they don't give a [ __ ] I
so check the a day talking my [ __ ] on
Twitter they're on Twitter about to
start sucking dick I think these two are
following some people you're following
oh yeah you've got to follow nobody
anybody wants to suck a dick pops up to
the top what do you want to hear about
Kobe or about some chicken some things
where the filters my [ __ ] is doing the
right [ __ ] there's some [ __ ] chick on
their second there I swear to God Jesus
it's some weird people doing some weird
stuff and I can't blame him they're
trying to make a [ __ ] living they try
to make the living I'm not mad nobody
makes a living I I don't I I know what
things I want to do and what I don't
want to do you know I'm fine for now
you know we're fine we'll struggle
through this it's gonna get worse before
it gets better as you seen right now but
who gives a [ __ ] there's no debtors
prison this has nothing to do with you
or you got to do is keep avoiding crowds
keep your mask on wash your hands and
when some other fun goes to hug them
[ __ ] Mason it's working I'm gonna get
myself all electrical guns that black
bag I shot with ya know what I'm one of
those people with those [ __ ] things I
D I fell like a [ __ ] but I promise the
other night I'm gonna just to keep in my
car you never not leave you never know
there's some weird things happening
people acting weird somebody might come
up to you and ask you for change when
you were in your pocket they want a mug
you don't know nothin
these are the times when you're driving
this stuff when you walk in the that's
why I don't even I don't even go to
7-eleven because there's such a negative
every time you go to 7-eleven there's
six people waiting for you the guy that
called a drop a [ __ ] napkin or your
phone so I don't even go down there it
does as it's got nothing to do with me
that's all you need to do is listening
so I keep getting out of control you
could do it two ways you could be a part
of it or you could you can be the
problem or you could be the solution you
know I'm not blaming nobody you know you
know me dawg I'm not rightly you want to
go to a bar girl oh boy I wouldn't go to
a bar there is nothing that I want to do
to be around people I know that this
grows around people okay if you go to a
bar listen we have a hard time social
distancing one was sober and you imagine
once you get three or four drinks and
you want to give everybody a hug right
so all these things are kind of on the
[ __ ] up part right now
comedy is booming in some [ __ ]
country either countries in some states
I [ __ ] love Carly I want you people
to go out and [ __ ] support but listen
you guys know 300 people in a room don't
work no unless you're a [ __ ] idiot
you know this just from New York that
really people in the room the
percentages are higher there's no
ventilation there's no windows there's
no [ __ ] fresh air yeah like I said
I'm not [ __ ] Fidel Castro I'm not a
tunnel buddy I don't live I'm telling
you how I'm gonna live you know next
week we're supposed to be in Brea I have
not heard anything they called last week
and said we're gonna be there next week
for sure we'll know Monday it's [ __ ]
Wednesday you know I haven't heard you
know noise me about you is how it like
you're right a lot and I was just
realizing the way you live like everyone
who I talk to and they're like so when
you have a podcast and look I don't know
if the people don't like they don't
understand and the way you live like is
just for today probably helped you for
this cuz I've never worried about no no
I'm telling you guys since the podcast
started it's all about today are you
gonna make money today are you gonna
make the work today are you gonna keep
together today
how you gonna feed your family today
when people come up to me and talking
about the future I don't know what
you're talking about I don't want to
talk about that's why I had a hard time
as comics I don't know what I want to do
it three months I'm gonna feel I'm full
of day last time I told you I wanted
chicken college today I woke up and I'm
gonna move
the pastrami sandwich this ain't
communist Cuba the same time this cube I
think most people waste their time
thinking about December I can't stand it
most people waste their time I mean I
get emails every day hey what are you
coming to Cleveland
you know what that's the wrong question
ask anybody what are you coming anywhere
you know I gotta have returned back like
are you [ __ ] [ __ ]
nobody's going nowhere nobody's you
don't want to be on a plane you don't
want your family on a [ __ ] plane so
we make it work or what we have I've
been having a good time I'm happy for
the first time in a long long long long
long time I'm happy from the inside out
I took a rest I saw what it was I saw it
was behind me and I'm also looking at
what's in front of me and I like what
I'm [ __ ] saying I don't want to do
the podcast to talk about something
today specifically because it's coming
up this weekend it bothered me for years
but now I'm enjoying it and it's [ __ ]
Father's Day three [ __ ] who
haven't even thought about it it's
Father's Day on Sunday so instead of
worrying about whether football's coming
back or whatever the [ __ ] is coming back
it's Father's Day
so hey your dad something I don't know
get him [ __ ] me on these buddy to
bother you well what's [ __ ] a little
beginning my father died when I was
three do I remember him I could tell you
whatever story you want me to tell you
but I don't remember I don't remember
them I remember situations but I don't
know more he was liked our numbers voice
I don't remember his tone so for years
growing up on father's day
I was bull said you know I'm trying yeah
one of my worst fears is my parents
dying I can't imagine growing up I'm
already dead
yeah so my father you know he was dead
so every year as a kid you know and I
had a stepfather than whatever but it
wasn't to say my father was dead I think
about him and I'd say what the [ __ ] you
know but I know he was watching over me
and I'd be fine and then you know you
turn 18 19 you get a little older
I still had those weird feeling my
mother died I never had anything against
mother's day and it'll really got sad on
Mother's Day I think only the first
three because at least I got to
experience my mother I got to see what
she was like I got the you know spend
time when I did everything well the she
was loved in my life but my fallen was a
big mystery of my [ __ ] life and then
now the questions I needed answered
nobody's around to answer for me so for
years I always didn't like Father's Day
and then what happened then I ended up
becoming a [ __ ] father and within two
years I wasn't mature enough to be a
father I mean you know I just didn't
have it in me to be a father and it
wasn't that I didn't have it in me it
was the addiction to when you addicted
to anybody you can't be committed to
anybody when you're addicted to a
[ __ ] drug you really can't be
committed to anybody they don't really
have you they have you 90% and guess
what The Tempest naughty 90% that's
exaggerating they have you 50% and the
50% that the drug you're addicted to is
the most powerful one so for years I
didn't you know after we broke up and I
lost my child father's day and was just
[ __ ] painful was [ __ ] you know what I
thought about it father's day for years
is what when I wake up at Father's Day
says from 1996 to 2013 you know what I
felt on Father's Day I stir him smelling
her like when we make these chains like
when I have visitation rights
I still remember gonna pick her up and
hugging her and I could smell his
Cologne he wore [ __ ] Cologne which
right there that's a sign that he's a
douche bag but whatever that was a long
time ago he walked along and I used to
[ __ ] smell the Cologne and listen I
don't know if you've been kicked in the
dick you've been kicked in the dick
it [ __ ] hurts but if you ever got
kicked mean addicting ball combo
it doesn't hurt it's a pain that if they
kick you correctly it shifts everything
in that's a horrible pain you feel in
your [ __ ] stomach I don't know if
that's ever happened to ya
that's the pain I would access when I
would bend over hug her and kiss her and
smell that [ __ ] Cologne in her the
anger everything the reaction to that
[ __ ] pain was so bad I can't even
explain it so that must have stayed with
me so from [ __ ] 2000 just think about
it from [ __ ] 1997
you know I mean listen when I was with
when I was a father for those five years
the mother wouldn't let me her
acknowledge me for father's death
like she would always make an argument
she wants to be with her grandfather on
Father's Day she wants to be with his
stepfather on Father's Day I mean they
got to that point like she wouldn't even
let her honor me on Father's Day which
was even more painful you know when I
think back to my addiction from 2098 to
the time I ended it was fueled by that
pain that was part of one of the many
many pains that I had was that you know
I just got the [ __ ] my [ __ ] blank
my legs kicked out from under me as a
dad and I got two ways to argue it I
could I can tell you two stories I can
tell you first of all I will tell you
the one story that some people are just
cruel sometimes I want to bust my balls
but they don't because I know the truth
people who say I abandoned Jackie I
never abandoned it when you abandon
somebody you go for cigarettes and you
don't come back with her I tried to keep
in touch with her I sent money child
support spayed up to you know I even
called years ago put an investigator on
it I never abandoned nobody I just knew
I wasn't gonna win so and I was gonna
end up in a bad place with these people
I see what buttons they were pushing
couple weeks ago I told you guys I don't
wanna go on the road right away because
I want to see how people react what I
just tell you what how did they react
well look at son look at southern
Florida look at Texas look at Arizona
look at California you have to wait to
see how people react
was I talking about who's doing the pain
she wouldn't like she wouldn't God your
father's gone at all and then four years
after that I never got nothing so
Father's Day was always [ __ ] was like
a double [ __ ] painful day you know I
got to the point where I was like I
don't even have [ __ ] kids like I
never saw kids again in my future I
could lie the entire I never saw it I
when I hooked up with Terry
now obviously 20 years later in two
weeks
I never saw a [ __ ] kids I thought my
sperm was so [ __ ] painted and my soul
was so [ __ ] black that there was no
love left in my sperm because the love
from yard has to travel to you sperm sac
and then you spread the love like it's
like sneezing with cold [ __ ] I'm saying
that sperm goes into that woman and you
spread love and the child I had a dark
heart in a dark soul and I was a junkie
so I never really thought I would
[ __ ] get it knocked her up I mean
that's true but it it really shows you
how sell awesome like similar we are
like looking at you you were a criminal
you'd been in prison I wouldn't really
think that either way Father's Day would
affect you emotionally at all but that's
it's done no matter what you've done in
your life what type of person you know
you have some emotion every soul man I
was watching I got I went down a foxhole
a buddy of mine to but the guys who used
to put me in the Disney scripts the dog
the same Halloween all that [ __ ] they
contacted me I can't say what they wrote
a script about but they wrote a a great
script and I want to do some background
and for some reason I bumped into the
Iceman's
tapes okay on HBO I don't know if you
guys are familiar with the oh yeah
richard kuklinski and i looked at the
first one when he first came on the
scene when Michael Bowden was doing the
interviews the guy who did the
independent autopsy on George Floyd that
guy that's the one you call when you
want to find out exactly what they died
of when he did the first interview I
think
was him you know he would talk to you
about killing people like nothing
happened but when you brought up his
family he would that's everybody has
some emotion everybody has some emotion
just because you got listen just because
you went to prison or you made a mistake
or people think you're the type of
Hannah more you are because you went to
prison that wrong bro you know I was
thinking about yesterday how I cried at
the time the time and I'm like people
would think I go people wouldn't dig
nothing because if you don't give a good
cry from time to time you ain't [ __ ] you
know something has to bring you to
emotion I got emotional watching the
last dance of Michael Jordan I got
emotional watching Bruce Lee I got
emotional watching this 44 434 30 this
week about the two home run hell yeah
that's you know yeah I like baseball I
miss baseball you know I miss baseball
how many times have we sat in I don't
watch sports but an hour before I leave
to go to the store to go out I would
watch a baseball game not really an hour
to with it hit let them go up and let
the other team bat I get up and I leave
but that's how much I like baseball like
I miss baseball right now oh yeah so I
think with this to double the 34 30 with
the homerun his I think he got me
emotional I found tears in my eyes and
I'm like what would people think
no people wouldn't think nothing because
I'm getting inspired when I see those
kind of shows I get inspired Bruce Lee
whether it was book the last dance of
Michael Jordan you know it just [ __ ]
inspires you you know what's really
burning me up right now there's
something that's burning me up it burned
me up the first time I saw it online and
that's why I stopped going online as
much as I do
I tell you what happened I've been
seeing people again I'm not defending
nobody I'm just telling you what I feel
I've seen people post George Floyd's
past and I've seen him post the
african-american man who died in an
Atlanta's police record you know what
man they both made a ton of mistakes
they both made a ton of mistakes you
know
does that give anybody a right what we
saw was one thing what they did in the
past was another it scares a guy like me
because what happens if God forbid
cannot like a home I go to bend over and
pick up a kettlebell and I have a heart
attack what do people come to be saying
tomorrow he was a good storyteller
he was an OK comic but that's right at
all he was in prison let's not make him
a martyr he went to prison
it's nothing going to prison is one
thing that's what he do after it that's
the other so I mean you gave me the best
compliment you gave me you go listen
I've started 20 podcasts of people
nearly one that worked is you who's an
ex-felon and the whole [ __ ] deal it
just shows you that we don't know
nothing about character of people you
know when Ari became my friend I became
my friend because of a personal
situation he has and he knows that
people make mistakes but in society they
automatically tell you you've been to
prison you're a bad person that's what
they teach you from day one without even
knowing what type of mistakes you're
gonna make as a young man whatever you
know or the thing that blows my mind is
how easy it is to go to prison obviously
you did some things and it was your
lifestyle but there's there's some
people you can just go and make one
mistake real quick and be there for 10
years like it like if it's crazy it's
that quick it's as quick as you were me
coming here bullshitting drinking having
a great time we each have three [ __ ]
beers three beers now if you look at me
I'm a fat [ __ ] you know three beers
ain't gonna do none of me but in
hindsight it will do something to me I
don't drink
so for gal like me I'll get [ __ ] up
guy like you you'll get [ __ ] up you
don't drink much you know right you're a
big little dude but you still you're not
gonna
no let's take my brother Bert who I
taught you yesterday online about the
[ __ ] the United closing let's take my
brother Bert broken dude three beers and
not feel a thing it's like a [ __ ]
check a shrimp cocktail damn right like
the weight of 200 300 milligrams is to
me three beers two bird is nothing you
know it and I know and everybody in this
fans listening to this knows it Bert
could drink anybody under the [ __ ]
table with no Coke god forbid that
[ __ ] big coke
a couple of weeks ago they were goofing
around him and Tom they're like what
would think what's a good drug for birth
to do you think he would enjoy cocaine I
go listen that guy puts away [ __ ]
cocktails with no cocaine I can't even
imagine giving him two lines it's all
over you might as well close the bar
because he's drinking everything he's
they gonna put the toilet right there
and let him go
seriously he could drink so let's say
Bert did three 12 ounce [ __ ]
Heinekens you and I both know Berkley
Drive with his eyes closed
I'm [ __ ] three Heinekens right you
could drive with his eyes closed on
three Heinekens Bert makes a right turn
on [ __ ] Chandler he's looking at to
see what's coming but he when he makes
the right turn he it's a bicyclist like
Wayne
okay runs over the guy they pull him
over just a little bit of alcohol on his
breath
you know not you know skyrocketing over
the legal limits whatever to you me it's
an accident the guys riding his bull he
wants to be speed racing you know so
what what do I do it burnt now so we
give him six years for manslaughter for
being drunk for a DUI it's the right
thing ba-ba-ba-ba I'm not saying that
that kind of snap is right but at the
same time we all know Bert we love Bert
does he deserve six years but that's how
quick your life could change yeah one
minute I was at the dentist office the
next minute I was putting a guy in
handcuffs putting them on the floor
dragging them into a room to our deaths
three-hour difference
that's how quick your life could change
you get in your car you wall with your
friends you have a few drinks you know
those are the one those are the guys
that when I got locked out one of my
friends that was the head of the laundry
was Steve Simone think about Steve
Simone
think about a guy like Steve Simone he
wasn't wrong you he wouldn't do he was a
great little white guy he was just
starting his sophomore year in college I
had [ __ ] uh not Colorado Springs but
Fort Collins
it's a veterinarian it specializes in
veterinary and he was interested he was
interested in animals he was a
sweetheart of a guy six [ __ ] year
sentence I got four he got six for
drinking and driving and killing
somebody I don't know what the [ __ ]
happened and then your life is never
over nothing and the guy he hit was
drunk like it was a complicated [ __ ]
they all left the bar together and there
was like an accident and six years six
years that guy that guy
that guy was destined that guy was not a
criminal by no means he was he was
destined to have a life I'd see his
family on visitation and they were white
and they were like mortified they would
sitting up in that visiting room like it
was the end of the world they had never
experienced this this was not in their
culture everybody else from that room
that culture was you know being in jail
or they had some previous these people
never had this in their whole life every
time they would come to visit him I
would look and I would feel horrible for
them and he would come over and
introduce me to his family like I met
him a couple times and they would look
at me like I was a [ __ ] Frankenstein
what they knew I was I had their sons
back right you know and they would talk
to me the more I'd see him then by
Thanksgiving they were nice to me
we both got sent in there like three
days apart or something Wow
so we were new so we clung I could tell
I could tell he was scared yeah his body
language was telling me he was scared so
I just wanted to assure him
he was alright he you know he was gonna
be okay and then he finally confessed to
me because I think he gonna rape me I
don't know look at this place we were at
a camp ain't nobody gonna rape you
unless you wanna be you know he was very
and then he felled into it and by like
November we were fine when I left he was
I forget what his name is you know I'm
sorry didn't keep in touch with him he
was a solid little friend to me in there
you know we didn't hang out together at
night because he was along the scan side
so he would stay in his room and read
his books and he kept himself he was
friends with the guys like
african-american guys in his wing made
him feel a little secure and you know he
helped people would get like he was one
of those guys that helped you read and
helped you get a high school diploma and
stuff like that so he finally fit in he
was pretty [ __ ] smart I write but my
heart went out from everyday cuz leave
he's living in a horror that he had
never shoplift in a lighter
he had never jaywalked but that's how
quickly your life could change you know
you are your buddy's house - guys I'm
watching football he Gamble's then get
into an argument the one guy calls the
wrong guy a [ __ ] Arab the other guy
calls him a [ __ ] [ __ ] mixing you
know somebody hit somebody with a thing
he had some they die you're there you
know so many things could happen in this
life
without your control that you don't
[ __ ] know but what do you do live
like a [ __ ] hermit in your basement
you have enjoy life and taking chances
you know yesterday I didn't want to
admit this to anybody two days ago you
know we put my daughter in a camp that
morning I had to take anxiety medication
I never things I have education in one
but at 7:00 a.m. when I woke up I was
such a [ __ ] inspector other anxiety
because I had to drop her off in a camp
I wasn't familiar with I went with the
mother we took a look around it wasn't
much but she seemed interested I looked
at her
she nodded and she ran it guys she ran
and that I had to say merci and she
turned around I go see you go see you
whoa she was dying to get away from us
three [ __ ] months in the house and
we've done everything we can with her
but she's so [ __ ] independent she
shot the [ __ ] out of there so all day I
was waiting and my phone on men waiting
for the call come get me
this sucks somebody hit me I thought all
these bad negative things my wife comes
to me she goes you want to pick her up a
master absolutely let's go see I was
just going to see what the reaction was
first hand I didn't want to hear from my
wife I pull up my wife loose you want to
come in and out I said in the car I made
a call I tried to call you the service
was down that day and next you know the
window is open I hate them both come out
my first thing I hear was mommy can I
come back tomorrow and my wife goes yeah
you do about my [ __ ] heart settled
everything went away that was the last
of my anxiety because now at least she's
got a camp got a hold her over right so
she gets bored which is about two weeks
right but by that time the other camp
will be ready with the pool hopefully if
the numbers don't go up and like this is
like such a good example of like people
changing cuz to me you look yeah that
kind of scared in jail that me I'd be
terrified and you now 20 years later
you're nervous that your daughter might
not enjoy camp this means I can't get my
book done right yeah I mean some
honorable she's on me all day so I'm
happy that plus I didn't wanna listen
this these last couple generations and
have come up you [ __ ] kids with your
[ __ ] computers understand and the
stain and [ __ ] drives me [ __ ]
crazy kids it drives me crazy I've never
seen a society like this every time I
open up my front door I looked on the
street and I hear kids playing my heart
breaks more and more then I write it off
to California then I got on a plane I
come to your town to visit to do comedy
for the weekend and that's the first
thing I do is I tell the guy let's go
down a residential
but there ain't no kids playing outside
no more I don't know what the [ __ ]
happened in society you know I want my
kid to be out and I want her girlfriends
to be out with him walk around get
involved go to the park and nobody gonna
kill you
just you know this is what we live in
nobody gonna kill you but I want her to
be out I wanna you know when this [ __ ]
when this [ __ ] happen from the beginning
I think it was the first week my wife is
like just waking up and doing home
school and I know that's not gonna work
I go you forget when you drop her off
she runs around for 20 minutes and she
talks and she gets her Yaya's up that's
what I call again you Yassa
she talks then you sit him down then you
teach them you teach them for an hour
and a half what's their [ __ ]
attention span that's going backwards
boom
you take him outside again throw him off
or different activity bring him back
maybe she would say to me I don't like
the sweat I don't give a [ __ ] what you
like you're gonna [ __ ] sweat you know
I got footage of me playing basketball
with her I got footage of me am I gonna
do drills through cones at the church
over there and they had cones set up for
people who would not go in right I used
them as drill calls I had a [ __ ]
doing basketball going around to the
[ __ ] cold I don't give a [ __ ]
you're not standing the [ __ ] out all
that so for me I'm going to camp yeah
help me out because what these kids for
the stand every day ten years from now
they're gonna be in a psychiatrist
because they're gonna be raised that's
those three months of fear you you see
the fear in your parents yeah so
obviously you're gonna be scared that's
why I couldn't be scared throughout this
I couldn't show her I was scared
throughout this I had a ticket to
McDonald's I didn't walking down till
you walk in there anyway you gotta be
crazy walking doing no that's all about
it called me especially now that's a
then they mix the gay parade with the
regular black protesters so now you make
some HIV with cold vid that's a [ __ ]
mixture you can't make in China time
they're gonna kill the world with that
mixture HIV and [ __ ] covent together
that's what I needed I love I'll be
teaching you and I love the [ __ ] law
blah blah you know I want everybody it's
freedom of [ __ ] speech but you can't
mix cuz you're gonna [ __ ] this up
I'm Sports crazy [ __ ] now they're
gonna had complete different symptoms to
calm it you know I'm saying you have an
itchy [ __ ] does your mouth feel like
you had a dick in it you know go to the
hospital it's [ __ ] Wednesday [ __ ]
like this whoo sparking another one with
me nobody go [ __ ] yourself I'm going
deep today
it's Wednesday that's not another tab
and I gotta go see my doctor tomorrow
for a [ __ ] blood test
wait they look at my blood guy's gonna
be covered in THC and the coal beds
beating the THC the debt he's beating
them on the head like see I don't like
the [ __ ] ante for whatever the [ __ ]
hit people to hell which stinks those
poor bastards or they're gonna get hit
now they got all these organizations the
boogaloos the [ __ ] keepers I don't
[ __ ] listen I can't keep up that's
where you got to carry two pistols do
they or do they have to test you for THC
further ado dr. okay let me explain
something my doctor don't want to test
me 50 AC B anyone - I got a new one but
Jimmy you don't want to know that I
don't thank you 48 seemly I don't know
the drugs can I just pull them blood
from you I'm looking for all the other
[ __ ] you know diabetes all that [ __ ] I
don't want to lose my foot and be on a
roller skate thanks to you and [ __ ]
how's your brother skate feel good this
diabetes is great purpose the good foot
the dew point is thump no wait I know
you I know you keep it up you're gonna
get back yeah well I switch feet those
little ones that they just gave you if
you will miss the leg
it's amazing we mentioned everybody here
we just use everybody gets love on the
podcast we just abuse one [ __ ] it now
everybody gets love gay people everybody
I love everybody I don't give a [ __ ]
anymore [ __ ] it we're all the same
everybody said we wall built at the same
factory brother get that through your
[ __ ] heads nobody were all the same
well whether you gay black I don't give
a [ __ ] anymore
I love usual won't go [ __ ] yourself if
you don't go listen to somebody else
anyway talking about Father's Day I
[ __ ] hated it and put him not in my
[ __ ] stomach then God gave me mercy
do you remember your first Father's Day
with her little painful at first the
first two were a little hard to digest
you know when somebody one for years
somebody tells you you're not a good dad
and then one day you realized you
weren't a good dad at that time because
after I had mercy and I think by the
time mercy was five I made a conscious
decision I think I saw a son on the
podcast that I was doing some of Mercy
one there and it fed her like it was her
and I had her like my wife had something
so out of fear do all that stuff I've
ever said next to her the same prayers
and thinking I could never have done
this 20 years ago like what I just did I
could have never done this when I was
going through all that stuff from my
older daughter little Jackie I couldn't
handle doing what I'm doing right now
and that's when I realized that I wasn't
ready to be a dad my ex-wife was right
my ex-wife was correct I was not by all
means ready for what I had on my plate
because of the coke because of my march
on this because of my hardheadedness and
my stubbornness I for her I didn't want
to lose my name to her I just wasn't
ready to be a dad at that
but when I did become maybe dad she was
all grown up and that's the truth
that's the honest-to-god truth now with
mercy came I was ready to be a dad and I
proved that to myself now so you know
what mercy seven I had Jack one till she
was five but I had my little situation
and I had to devote myself to comedy
gave my wife and out they took in the
England we lost contact for a while on
purpose then I called the house and
reconnected from there on and it was
just a wall and valued and I came to
grips with it and then God through
Jackie and my father mercy on my lap
just because I came to grips and what
had happened boom God through a [ __ ]
fastball up and guess what I headed out
of the [ __ ] Park and now today yet
today I feel like a debt I'm ready to
accept the gift on Sunday and tell her I
love and hang out with her I don't know
where we're gonna go everything's
[ __ ] closed you know I was hoping you
the universe was open but the rides
aren't you can still go up there park
for free I have walked some of the
restaurants are open you know I don't
know if I'm ready it up and put an apron
on and grill outside uncle Joey's the
master a lot of things they're all
psychological cooking my wife
interesting yeah I don't see me that's
like that's like that's how I know I'm
not really a dad okay because my dad
didn't do a lot of kids stuff he did
some stuff well he was always outside
with the other grill and you how to do
that I didn't go stay in the child when
I was on the coke in 95 91 I didn't
understand the child I was still a
[ __ ] child yeah I was still a child
who was on drugs but regressed 20
[ __ ] times you know it's you know I
wasn't [ __ ] ready that's why I know
now in my heart that well with mercy and
I do little things you know especially
during this quarantine
I've I've made something of this quality
I'm very happy that I made something of
myself during this quality I got
stronger
I took a breather and let me look at
myself my past and let me look at my
future arms and I suggested to you guys
I told you since day one get your money
back from those tickets I'm not that'll
you don't get your money back
something doesn't feel right pack your
refrigerators with food put away your
money get your weapons ready and get
your explosives just in case somebody
wants come in your [ __ ] door because
listen in two weeks if we don't go back
to work or if they start doing shut-ins
or whatever just because things are open
don't mean restaurants are doing great
yeah I spoke to my friend yeah there was
a Thai restaurant 200 hours on Friday
the two hundred dollars worth of
business on Friday so we expect it to
reopen for all these people to come out
and be spending money and be like
nineteen twenty it's not happening but
listen Florida they're going out and I
resolve they're going out and in Texas
they're going out big time and listen
like I said I'm not Fidel Castro I'm not
Fidel Castro by no means I'm sure if I
was 18 I'd still be I pissed on coconut
mask I'm a little bit you know me I'm
not gonna lie nobody but just be just
keep your eyes open man you know what
avoid the [ __ ] how if it if it's over
eight people you don't want to [ __ ]
really be there you don't wanna be there
let's learn let life dictate itself I
would love to do comedy next weekend did
you see that [ __ ] Jack Jun it posted
he was doing the show when is that no he
was doing the show Wednesday tonight
tonight he was doing a show and a plan
to advertise they called them up he said
listen I don't know if you know this you
ain't doing no show Wow
they said we don't give up what the
numbers are down we don't give a
Frenchman's [ __ ] you ain't doing no show
you want to open up the show chicken
wings go ahead you want to saw a couple
cocktails
then Jack junior said what we'll do in
the backyard and they said no you want
so that's just so you people know what's
going on in California
well you posted the other day they
already canceled the Oscars yeah well
they they canceled the Oscars for the
wrong reasons I'm very sorry I posted
that they didn't cancel the Oscars
because they expect some they canceled
the oxes because they're not shooting no
movies right now okay
so there's such a three month gap
nobody's gonna wind up there's only
three movies going up against themselves
so they want to give people an
opportunity to get their movies out
there
I mean I'm expecting to hear from The
Sopranos any day now I'm the prequel any
day and when I hear from them it's gonna
be a week later they're flying me it I'm
gonna hear from them to go take a cobra
test it to send them the results and
then they'll see from there and they'll
plan the whole thing after that when I
land at the airport don't give me a cold
boot test they'll give me a covert test
at the hotel before I check in on the
set and then after the set whatever it's
gonna be a quick shoot
you can't shoot long hours so I'm
expecting that and that's it that's all
I know for right now all I know is today
like you said to me today guys look I
learned a long time ago I saw people who
sat there and made plans for [ __ ]
three years the garbage needs to come
now this is what I'm saying the hits
don't stop I had an ambulance chase I
had [ __ ] Johnny helicopter out there
for ten minutes now I got this guy going
back but you don't want to hit nobody
ain't nobody out there turn the [ __ ]
beeper off and if you hit somebody then
you just take off go [ __ ] it I don't
know nothing who hit him Kovac
I love this marijuana guys
I love Wednesday's must be playing well
it's hump day no one better get stoned
to the [ __ ] gills and look at life
for what it is you collect unemployment
whatever the [ __ ] you're doing
there's no debtors prison hang on
[ __ ] but anyway back to Father's Day
man I became a dad and I'm [ __ ] happy
so thank you very much and you guys
helped a lot you
guys helped a lot with your emails and
your questions a lot of people
questioned my story about Jackie and
what happened today whatever you want to
believe whatever put-down you got from
me God believe it but I'm telling you
right now nobody got abandoned nobody
was missing [ __ ] meals everything was
planned everything I saw the future I
was like listen this is either gonna
hand me up in prison or something bad is
gonna happen again
either way I'm gonna lose I had already
been thrown out of the county works on a
fake [ __ ] sexual I'd grab some girl's
ass charge and I knew that that was just
the beginning of the [ __ ] coming my
way so I'm happy I took the sign listen
that's what I was trying to say to you
people sometimes life gives you [ __ ]
signs you don't need to even get
involved sometimes life will give you
signs and it's not more eminent to me
then when I started doing stand-up
comedy you got to read the signs life
gives you and roll with it it's not
gonna happen
maybe that's the way whoever's watching
over me Buddha did you God God he hide
whatever who's ever looking hoping that
his name jihad I don't find who's ever
looking over you that's not the way you
want it if bran opens next weekend I'm
very happy you know if prayer doesn't
open I'll wait till July for the
residency I don't want people getting
sick either so I'm working everything on
signs that's why right now the sign is
to sit tight put your mask on you want
to exercise be my guest if you want to
take your mask off if you're outside up
to 20 minutes and you're by yourself and
you're socially distancing and you're by
yourself and you don't have 20 people
walking in front of you you can take
that mass now oh yeah if you're white
outside because you're gonna get co2
whatever that has been poisoning I got
it too one day on the bicycle that's
great I kept the mask on the whole time
and you can't do that when you pull over
I
leave it off now they take like a minute
break and drink water and breathe take
deep breaths because that mask I'm
telling you it's [ __ ] amazing what
how bad I felt that day
I can't we're working out yeah so you
know it'll give you oxygen poisoning or
some [ __ ] something something but poison
that I was reading about the other day
and I didn't know about it until it
happened to me I've gotten poison two
[ __ ] times the last couple of months
I got this [ __ ] other poison then
last I got the Sun poisoning day so last
night my wife was taking sheets her skin
off my back
guys sheets of skin were peeled off my
back
every time I scratch I feel water
because I got water blisters all over my
shoulders my [ __ ] my face my face for a
couple days that's how bad I got [ __ ]
burn last Wednesday at the beach with
twenty two layers of Sun powder on
whatever the [ __ ] Sun in tanning lotion
ah that's crazy I feel oh my god I was
burnt too [ __ ] is that
but I'm CUBAN I'm CUBAN I'm used to this
[ __ ] I've been getting Sun on my I love
the Sun my leg is a [ __ ] dark [ __ ]
dark dark time I got but my legs didn't
get sunburned it was just my shoulders
the inside of my back and my wife must
have put Sun ton she even said last
night she goes this is amazing I put
that stuff on you like four times I know
that's how strong the [ __ ] Sun was so
I'm alright though man [ __ ] I went to
Nova Thor yesterday I got my little red
light therapy how'd you go freezing it
I haven't frozen I'm not I haven't
worked myself up to freeze yet that's
next week
interests tomorrow I got the physical
that's the blood draw and the doctor's
office it's gonna be a big that's gonna
be a big yeah that's a lot of breathing
that's a lot of nose breathing you're
outside blood outside yeah yeah yeah for
me don't take me outside and stick a
finger up my ass outside I love your
questions they're always so yeah I'm
thinking about side that's great
anyway this is what I got to deal with
on a daily base
last week we were talking about places
to move he was thinking about Oklahoma I
went over that way I could see if we had
some that come in from or you never even
met nobody from Oklahoma yeah and this
is without we the drugs people put up
with the edible so you have no prices of
houses where Oklahoma City for what has
good decent weather and doesn't
hurricanes but in the mind the houses
are cheap that's always like you know
where the houses are cheap workers there
was a bomb in there you stupid [ __ ] you
know moving Oklahoma you can't be that
[ __ ] that you look to the homes you
see was that big people you see that put
up with on a daily and you're lucky in
it yet they call me on edibles I didn't
even know you'll even know what the [ __ ]
he's saying mom I was a homily an
apology last night and it wasn't even
that night it was the next day so please
knock it off you lost all credibility
wants to move to Oklahoma
un-fuckin'-believable and do what hang
out with Indians I don't know what do
you do what do you know anybody in
Oklahoma for Christ sakes go home with
your mother leave please go to Boston
live in the basement moving anywhere
fold your clothes if you think you can
sit down man - whatever san gennaro de
the Armenian we'll come get you in a few
months he'll take it at Easton what's
the code big cookie man all those fat
[ __ ] right now in the Armenian trying
to lose weight the Houston those poor
fat bastard 600 pounds I can't leave the
house the Armenians you I love smoking
marijuana especially on the podcast with
you people so it gives me a nice little
feeling I got tingles I start the day
off on the right [ __ ] foot and that's
it and that's that listen people because
of this covert thing there's some people
I want in here and there's some people I
don't want in here so for a couple days
for a couple podcasts gonna be one with
a guest one with us you better get used
to we're just like coming here drop
knowledge crack a couple jokes keep you
on track
and that's it you're onto your [ __ ]
day we don't have time no more there's
people going to [ __ ] parades people
are jumping up and down and
who the [ __ ] coming in here and right
now at this point in my life I gotta
look out for me I gotta look out for
Lisa at night I look out for my [ __ ]
family you know we don't see me out on
the road don't get mad at me again I
gotta think of the big picture I can't
think of what I want
yes Dwight I miss going onstage are you
[ __ ] kidding me
every night I sit there at eight o'clock
oh Jesus Christ
yeah and I just took a right off over
Laurel Canyon just to make you feel like
I was going to Tommy's door I got the
low King and I went over I may believe I
wasn't going to that McDonald's you
really can't go in that way and I made a
u-turn I came right back up Laurel
Canyon I didn't even go by the store I
just wanted to make the drive
it took me eight point nine minutes
there was not one [ __ ] soul on Laurel
can you know what up and over again as
far as next weekend I don't know what's
gonna happen in Brea it's Wednesday and
I haven't heard anything and I'm sorry
hopefully by tomorrow I could post
something on there cuz it'll give you a
week out and we'll see if there's going
to be a hundred people 200 people or
there's not gonna be a show at all but
don't worry about it because starting I
think July 13th
it's Brea one week Oxnard the next and
brand the following week and then I got
other things in the store and I'm gonna
be dropping on you people so listen
you're having a rough time I'm having a
rough time we're all having a rough time
but guess what we're having a rough time
together that's better than doing it
along I love you guys with all my
[ __ ] heart I know you're going
through hell thank you for all the early
happy Father's Day already I got them
last night Tuesday night
people like Joey happy follow this I
said you know what tomorrow we'll do a
little podcast just to let you know I
feel about Father's Day I'm comfortable
now I'm comfortable because of my
daughter I'm comfortable because of my
wife and I'm also comfortable because of
the way you guys have nurtured me
throughout this time you know before my
wife had mercy I was now I didn't think
I could live up to it I thought I was a
failure I had failed once before what's
gonna make me not fail
again but this time I had to do it for
myself I had to do it for her and how to
do it for you guys don't when you trust
back just to let you know I didn't just
abandon a child so this Sunday means the
world to me so thank you very much for
listening thank you for smoking two
joints in me thank you for letting me
come on and break your balls for a few
hours and that's it if you took offense
anything go [ __ ] yourself these are just
jokes it's a comedy podcast not a
[ __ ] you know but whether the
choleric podcast I'm at here will press
nobody I'm just gonna have a good time
for an hour and let you know I got your
back all right real quick before I get
you out of here real quick want to talk
to you about something listen I was
having a rough time everything got
together I found the bike guys I got my
mind right I went back to the notebook
the notebook was important and listen
what Lee was saying in the beginning yes
I live for the daily I live for today
but I live for 90 days from here I live
for 30 days man and I live on a daily
thirty when you have a notebook it's a
daily goal the 30-day goal the 60-day go
the 90-day goal and the one-year going
on where you want to be that's the
breakdown I focus on the today I go
every day I write every morning I write
a journal and every morning I write what
I want and how what I need to do to get
that so it's not I want a Maserati I
want to get my dick sucked eight times a
day well what do you need to do to get a
Maserati I need to get out of the house
I need to [ __ ] make money how are you
gonna make money break it down write it
down for me write it down for me to the
[ __ ] letter how you gonna make money
and write it down close that notebook
and go back and look a month later and
see what happens to your [ __ ] life
I've been doing it now
little by little at the beginning I was
just on the daily I was just going out
health forget about money forget about
anything else just to stay healthy just
to keep my cortisol level down side
you know people would die we you did
that from a heart attack right now from
stressing out about you builds your
small business your money your whatever
I told you there's no debtors there's no
debtors prison so the first thing we had
to focus on to move forward was out my
health my wife's health and my
daughter's health we have adjusted by
the Mandy exercise everybody's
exercising you know I will read and
write I cut bacon out of my diet the
bacon out of my [ __ ] diet I'm damn it
you know how much I hate scrambled eggs
except with ketchup that's what brings
the white trash out of me
scrambled a detective who [ __ ]
delicious with a piece of [ __ ] wheat
bread in the morning so I cut my points
down for breakfast it takes me a lot
longer so guys listen I I don't just
talk to talk I walk the [ __ ] walk
with you guys I'm here with you and
that's it and that's that now the guys
decided to make a [ __ ] reverse again
you see I live with do you see that
[ __ ] live with I love I want I want
to just take the go backwards listen to
this it's all over you Sam
I can't [ __ ] win anyway I hope you
listen anyway real quick I want to talk
to you about another company right here
who I love to death why because if it
wasn't for them my wife would be
miserable
stamps.com listen to me
stamps.com brings the post office into
the comfort of your own home
skip the line print postage 24/7 any
letter any size package going anywhere
in the world right from your couch and
the best part is the mailman will come
and pick it up no contact required it's
that simple
everyone is avoiding crowds right now
but when you need to go to the post
office print postage at home and skip
the lines with stamp calm Plus save
money on discounts you can't even get at
the post office and now stamps calm is
working with UPS if you don't know now
you know
get what get discounts up to 62 percent
off that's what I'm talking about
get five cents off every first class
stamp and up to 62 percent off on
shipping that is [ __ ] huge savings
especially now save up to 62 percent on
UPS rates are you crazy
Plus never pay residential surcharges
again you can't beat that so do me a
favor if you have a small business you
some t-shirts pictures whatever how are
you doing
this is the way to go you want to be a
[ __ ] machine you want your business
to be a [ __ ] machine go to stamps
calm is a no-brainer
especially now because they're gonna
save you time and money and keep you
safe by avoiding [ __ ] crowds anywhere
okay so right now they got a special
offer do me a favor for the church
family eight I know you're struggling
this is the way they could make a
comeback
four week trial period plus free postage
and a digital scale joy what are you
talking about four week trial free
postage and a digital scale no long term
commitments of contracts it's easy just
go to stamps.com click on the microphone
at the top of the homepage and press in
church oh yeah
what are you crazy you're gonna save 62%
on UPS and you get five cents off every
first-class stamp who does that for you
uncle [ __ ] Joey go to
stamps.com
click on the microphone at the top of
the homepage and press in church give
the hub astir some work she's a [ __ ]
mailman that [ __ ] gonna stamps
calm and press in church and stay safe
my friends listen first of all I want to
wish all the fathers listened to a
podcast a happy Father's Day from the
bottom of my heart and all the mothers
cuz you mother's a part-time [ __ ]
father's too and that's it and that's
that I hope you have a great weekend I
hope you stay safe I hope you stay
healthy I hope nothing gets into your
way your mask wash your hands
the [ __ ] they tailored to just do if
it's six feet go eight feet drink your
water bang your wife and that's it
spread the love brother that's all you
got nothing to be angry about you know
why your mother [ __ ] alive that's the
most important thing everything else
there's no debtors prison somebody'll
give you a [ __ ] Apple you can always
hit some lay ahead you know something
something's always up I love you guys
thank you very much for listening to the
Church of what's happened now
we'll see you Monday morning bright and
early tip-top Magoo ready to go stay
black have a great weekend kick this
[ __ ] melee
[Music]